This is the new Sajara in town. On the
day of judgment, the first thing we will
be asked about is our prayer. Now,
imagine being part of a project that
teaches thousands of people around the
world for just 100.
>> You can help teach 20 to 60 people like
me learn how to pray salah.
>> And when they teach their children
>> and their children's children,
>> the reward continues. Do not miss the
kajaria.
>> Donate today
>> and earn rewards that last beyond your
lifetime.
>> Go to the link and donate now.
>> Like you just have this level of respect
for one another that it like transcends
race, religion, like nationality,
country. It's just
it's something that you just don't know
after like you kind of become someone's
brother after you and him try to die.
Win or lose, you know.
>> Hamzad shocked Strickland. Why now? Did
he really lose that uh fight and what is
the ultimate fight about? Now, we're
going to break down this inshallah
because you know why guys I believe
Hamzat actually won that fight in a
different way and because in this life
brother and sisters our fight is not who
is stronger like the prophetam said
strong is not the one that can wrestle
another person down. Our fight should be
for the sake of Allah subhanaa tala in
his course. Now in that fight I genuely
believe yes it might be the point
decision went towards Strickland.
However, I believe he pulled such a
move. The way he carries himself and it
goes back to Now, before we get into all
of that though, MMA is haram. Music,
half naked girls, gambling, etc. It is
all haram. We've said this long time ago
for those idiots. Yeah. Out there
saying, "Oh, the da bros." Yeah, we
spoken about this long time ago. I maybe
talking about some fake dows. Okay. It
is not a sport that's permissible.
Khabib himself knows this. But what
we're going to watch now, inshallah, is
the reaction of Strickland. you know
when the belt was put around him the way
about it a lot of Muslims got upset and
I thought to myself no there's a lot of
wisdom behind it and I believe we assume
the best that the move that he done the
video that we're going to watch of the
interview of Sean Strickland he you can
see his tones change and I genuinely
believe he will not be talking against
Muslims and all this kind of stuff again
I genuinely believe this why because
Allah says in the Quran and I believe
this is what um orchestrated okay this
is what he done he implemented Allah
says in the Quran, repel evil with that
which is good and you will see that you
will see peace and friendship between
the person that you had emnity with
sometimes brothers and sisters the best
way is love manners and goodl let's
watch the video for ourself inshallah
>> this might be a bit of a weird question
but because you know look you went
through five rounds together and stuff
like that were you kind of happy that
Hamza was willing to squash the beef
with you too
>> yeah no I mean And you guys, I go so
hard on everybody and there's always
truth to what I say and there's always,
you know, it's there's always truth to
what I say, but at the end of the day,
man, all the hate and all the hates out
of me. I need I need the hate battery
charged, so I need a couple days. But
>> I know you guys squash the beef, but did
you expect Hamza to actually wrap the
belt around you? You know, man, there is
something and like you guys can't unless
you've experienced it. You just don't
know what it's like when you go and
fight another man and like, bro, your
soul is just exposed. When you're
bleeding and he's bleeding and like I
want to quit, he wants to quit. We don't
want to be there. Like, you just have
this level of respect for one another
that it like transcends race, religion,
like nationality, country. It's just
it's something that you just don't know
after like you kind of become someone's
brother after you and him try to die win
or lose you know
>> so so yeah I mean like in in obviously
in the ring you know you were going to
have respect for another because it is a
a place in that but I believe the the
the I don't think those disrespects
towards one each other was orchestrated
per se I believe they genuinely were
saying that to each other and uh again
bringing the whole thing of you know
saying Allah abbar to the to the fight
etc which he scolded another person for
doing a little hypocritical but the
point is this you can see clearly that
the respect that they have for one
another in the ring to see that you're
there to fight is one thing but I
genuinely believe that the way went
about things and the way he put the belt
on him show them respect etc uh which is
something that is our dean that teaches
really really uh changed uh shan
strickland and this is why he's so
profound say sometimes you will see the
prophetam yes when there are people who
are very hostile towards him he didn't
do that that's why I believe I belief
that he may have lost the fight per se
there but he won uh he might have lost
the battle but he won the war or should
we say he may have lost that fight but
he won Shan Strickland and that respect
will stay with Shan Strickland and that
respect that that thing that could
change you and say you know hold on a
second I call these guys this and that
and they're terrorists and blah blah
blah but that thing how you make someone
feel and the respect you give them by
putting the belt on them yes you might
be like this aggressive or you know
you're calling them this and I'm going
to rip your head off and Allahbar etc.
But when all has settled down the way
you carry yourself is very very
important and that's why the prophetam
said yes that I came for nothing but to
perfect good manners and goodl the
prophetam's and manners was a evidence
to his prophethood that's why many
people believed in him and said oh this
is impossible yes except those who were
true disbelievers even though they knew
it was a truth but because of their
arrogance they did not so here brothers
and sisters I genuinely believe And even
that I've seen a video which I want to
show you guys Strickland talking about
uh for example let's just watch it for
oursel talking about the Palestinians. I
don't I don't think I think this is old
or new but there we go. You know what
have we been hearing for the last year
and a half we've been seeing on the
internet on the interwebs on the X from
CNN from all the all the media we've
been seeing dead little brown kids being
pulled out of buildings. Every time I go
on the news, I see Israeli bombs a
hospital. Here's a dead little
Palestinian girl before she wears a
hijab. And like it's the only time you
can see her face. But it's real sad.
Like you can't be a human being and turn
the news on and see these dead kids
missing limbs and not feel anger. And
not feel anger. Well, godamn. I don't
want little brown kids to die anymore. I
want that to stop. The American military
is giving Israelis bombs to bomb little
brown kids in hospitals. Like if you had
a if you had a a button right now and
you could stop giving bombs to Israel,
would you to kill little brown kids?
Naturally, yes. And you and every other
American would. But it doesn't stop.
There you go. I think that might be an
old video, but I genuinely believe that
he was already being a bit more
sympathetic. But with this behavior of
Hamzat what he showed I genuinely
believe this verse in the Quran where
Allah says repel evil that with that
which is good and you will see the one
that you have enmity with there will be
friendship. I genuinely believe this is
what's going to happen and I genuinely
believe you're not going to hear from
Sean Strickland and these Islamophobic
comments and this is why brother sisters
sometimes actions and a lot of times
actions and manners is the greatest form
of da you can ever give. I want to leave
that with you guys. Inshallah comes out.
You may have lost the fight but you sure
won Shan Strickland. May Allah guide
Shan Strickland to Islam and make it a
means that he embraces the true faith.
Till next time. Forehead.